July 4th 1776 word has traveled from the
front that the British Army is advancing
which is a super inconvenient time for
George Washington and Thomas Jefferson
to discover that Ben Franklin has taken
the Declaration for safekeeping and
spent the night in a brothel a long
corridor with half a dozen bedroom doors
muffled sounds of bed creaks and
pleasure on the other side
Ben Ben you in here
Jefferson opens the first door appears
in we see from his reaction to whatever
that there are sex going in on inside
he's frozen Washington slams the door
and pushes Jefferson to the next how the
hell have you never been to a brothel
it's just not my thing okay I'd rather
crawl up next to a rope roaring fire
with a lady who loves me hmm maybe the
volume of chaucer [ __ ] like that is why
people think you're weird
Washington throws open the last door
Interior brought the bedroom des the
guy's Russian to see been tied to a
broken bed nude little Franklin is
flopping around the room shows evidence
of a scandalous night that should never
be spoken of again
there's empty liquor bottles and whips a
saddle and Indian headdress melted
candles Jefferson quickly throws a sheet
over Ben's prune junk where's the
Declaration oh hey I met the most
wonderful woman last night you should
have seen her the agony and ecstasy
Jefferson and Washington dig through the
damage searching by the third hour we
had become as wild animals thrashing
about in burning desire by the fifth
hour we were human once more and a
little chafed to be honest
Jefferson starts to untie Franklin but
Ben squirms away Elvis help us look
no no she promised a hasty return get
out both of you you spoil the mood
Jefferson opens a cabinet a pig wearing
girlie panty squeals and runs out
Jefferson jumps back were pulse forcibly
unties Franklin oh your papers are with
my latest blueprints on the table
Franklin looks over at the table it's
empty damn it Ben it's got to be here
somewhere
Franklin Gibson and joins the search
still News oh we probably have time for
you to get dressed
Franklin shrugs begins to dress starts
with his undershirt then top shirt
buttons each then his puffy tie pants
first George what is the point of
freedom if you can't let it all hang out
Franklin notices a pair of Claire's pink
panties lying under his feet he secretly
snatches them in his pocket it ain't
here
poor girl an unwed woman in this day and
age can't kid must do what she can to
scrape by she robbed you and yet I don't
care young man that is how you know it
is love there's no point arguing with
the old man just hurry up and write
another one are you kidding
that was months of work this is a
document that defines a country you
can't just rattle that [ __ ] off sure he
can easy how about hey you uppity
bastards
get the [ __ ] out signed us yeah yeah I
mean except I I maybe added all the
names of who oh dear God why did you do
that I'm sorry I was just I I thought I
could maybe sneak my name in there just
really small so no one noticed
you know Hancock was gonna sign so
freaking big I thought maybe I could get
away with it well [ __ ]
that's like hidden and in those bridge
shits achilles colonies already arguing
with each other all damn day murder a
couple delicates to see how much unities
left they're all gonna sign anyway with
plans to go into hiding afterwards
there's 55 of us impossible to get word
to all of our colleagues fast enough how
bad is it it's cold red man worst-case
scenario if that document is kept from
the British and not delivered to the
Continental Congress tonight there will
be no America
Jefferson plops on the edge of the
broken slanted bed swipes a bottle of
whiskey from the nightstand and skwiggs
and it's all my fault oh god what are we
gonna do George option a walk up to the
nearest British and cabman turn
ourselves in and enjoy a life of service
on our knees under good ol king george's
balls jefferson takes a longer swing I
can't do that
Church of England would have me burned
at the stake for most of what I did last
night
option B you take the next ship to South
America live in hiding as disgraced
traders drinking subpar rum in massive
enough quantities to forget we once took
a huge pile on the once great colonies B
it is
and what else we have we can go out
there put some american-made boots up
some elitist [ __ ] and get the
goddamn Declaration of Independence back
Jefferson invigorated slims the whiskey
down marches to the window hands on hips
Franklin joins hands on hips to the
three amigos the only difference
Franklin's still not wearing any pants